you became close with Arnold while
making the film it was truly a joy like
a dream to work with and he was lovely
and he said yes to a lot of dumb things
we have him wear some absurd costumes
and he dresses in later hosen at one
point and we have a picture yeah we have
a picture of him in later house and wait
on the memory area his own his own
personal later hoes us his later he had
flown up from LA we shot in Vancouver
and I went camping with my family this
past weekend and the movie just opened
up theatrically and we returned home to
find a gift waiting for us from Arnold
on our front porch and I think we have a
picture of that Oh beautiful balloon is
a balloon replica of Arnold in later
hose exactly right what a weird thing it
was weird and it's odd but it lives with
us now okay
we're making the most of it and I may be
getting too comfortable with it quite
honestly and I think we have a picture
of that
[Applause]
hot at least moving to the side yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you